>> Male presenter: All right good afternoon
everyone. Today Pawnee's finest comes to our
Los Angeles office for a Talks at Google presentation.
We've rolled out the Tom Haverfoods in our
café, including waffles, all the bacon and
eggs we could have. Unfortunately, we're still
working on a way to integrate the Ron Swanson
Turkey Burger into our nutritional guidelines.
But research is still ongoing there. But now
we're really ready to treat yourself. We have
four amazing members of the Parks and Rec
crew here today to talk about their new season,
season 5, which starts on September 20 on
NBC Thursdays. We have Amy Poehler, Adam Scott,
Chris Pratt and Aubrey Plaza in essence the
cutest couples from the show.
[Applause]
>> Presenter Please join me in welcoming Parks
and Rec to Google.
[applause and cheering]
>> Amy Poehler: Hi, everybody how you doing?
Thank you for having us. My name is Amy Poehler
I'm with Adam Scott, Aubrey Plaza, Chris Pratt.
We make up part of the cast of Parks and Recreation.
We're so happy we could join you here today.
We should say welcome to the the Parks and
Recreation's Google talk and it's going to
last about an hour and then we will participate
in a Google hangout after that.
>> Adam Scott: Is that just where we just
hang out? [laughter]
>> Amy: Yeah, we're just going to hang out.
>> Adam: Like super cas- stuff?
>> Amy: Right, if it all goes well it may
turn into a Google make out. [laughter] Where
we let people come up and make out with us.
[laughter] And then, then there's going to
be Google sex, [laughter] which is self-explanatory
and then a Google walk of shame.
[laughter]
>> Aubrey: And then a Google morning after
pill?
>> Amy: That's right. A morning after pill.
[laughter] That's right.
>> Adam: But if that doesn't work
>> Amy: Then it'll be a Google, Google 'why
isn't the audience calling me back?' [laughter]
I would like to say that Michael Schur the
creator of Parks and Recreation was supposed
to be here, and unfortunately he could not
make it. He was working really hard on our
next script. It's very, very complicated and
he's sorry he can't be here, but he wants
you to know that he's working very hard and
it's tough work because we are entering into
season 5, the Rise of the Dragons. [laughter]
Which is what we're working on now. OK, so
we are gonna, I am going ask you guys questions
like I don't really know you, I guess.
>> Adam: OK, Hi I'm Adam.
>> Amy: Hey, nice to meet you. [laughter]
Those kind of stuff those kind of cool handshakes
we do on set. First of all, you all look very
young and nice. This is being broadcast on
the internet.
>> Adam: I was going to ask what the hell
this was.
>> Amy: Yeah this is a thing that's on the
internet and then people all over the world
will be able to download it. That's exciting.
You guys are drinking beer.
>> Chris: Yeah, my sponsor doesn't even know
how to use the internet, so. [laughter]
>> Adam: I'm his sponsor.
>> Amy: OK, so lets get started and then we'll
go into questions from the audience and then
I guess eventually from the internet at some
point.
>> Chris: Oh great! Because we are at Google
and this is where the internet was invented,
technically. [laughter]
>> Amy: That's right. Technically. And I don't
really know how it works but I think people
at home get to just yell their question into
their computer and then it pops up into our
brains.
>> Chris: Whoa!
>> Adam: So if you yell loud enough, it just
goes straight to our brains?
>> Amy: Yeah.
>> Adam: That's crazy.
>> Amy: I know, it's amazing. I mean guys
the information highway is just.
>> Adam: It's straight to our brains.
>> Chris: This is the future. No hover boards,
but they got this.
>> Adam: Actually I saw they're not making
hover boards here.
[Laughter]
>> Amy: Just backpedaled on that. OK, guys!
I'm hoping that most of the people here have
watched Parks and Recreation or have seen
it.
[Applause and cheering]
>> Amy: Thank you. And the writers have done
an amazing job of creating real characters,
seemingly real crazy characters. So one of
the things that people like about Parks is
how much characters grow, the characters grow
over time. Where do you see your characters
in 10 years?
[Laughter]
>> Amy: There's no one else on the end, Pratt.
>> Chris: Is it my, is it for me?
>> Amy: Sure for all of us, for all of us.
>> Chris: Ten years from now?
>> Amy: Yes.
>> Adam: From ten years ago.
>> Chris: OK, I was going to say. I don't
know if that meant. Well, I'm pretty sure
I just don't want any spoilers, spoiler alerts
because ten years from now there will still
be Parks and Recreation on the air and you'll
just have to tune in.
>> Amy: Alright, good. I would do this job
for another ten years.
>> Chris: Oh my God. Please let us do it for
ten more years. [laughter]
>> Amy: Please let the show for 15 years.
15 seasons. [laughing] I want to be like the
Simpsons of mockumentary comedy.
>> Adam: By the way, in ten years, television
shows will be beamed directly in your brain.
>> Amy: That's right, you won't even need
a screen.
>> Adam: We won't even need to act them out.
We'll just, notions of what we want to do
will go to the brains of the audience.
>> Amy: Ooh, I like that.
>> Adam: Yeah so we can do it from our houses.
Because we'll be so sick of each other anyway,
it'll be great. We can just sit in our houses
and think about our characters.
>> Amy: [giggling] And then theater will just
be that you stick you hand in like a jelly
and you're like "Broadway"! [laughter]
>> Amy: Does anyone else want to talk about
their character in ten years or should I move
on? Plaza?
>> Aubrey: I think, that April and Andy will
still be married.
>> Chris: Assuming we survive the zombie apocalypse.
[Amy cracks up}
>> Aubrey: Right. I think we'll have five
kids and
>> Amy: Five in ten years?
>> Aubrey: Yeah.
>> Amy: I like that.
>> Chris: Quintuplets. They'll all be nine
years old, in ten years. She's pregnant with
five kids right now. [laughter]
>> Aubrey: I want that. I think April should
be pregnant soon and have multiple fetuses.
[laughter]
>> Amy: That's a question, that's actually
a question that some, coming down, I don't
know if we could do it during the talk, I
think, I don't know if we could only do it
during the hangout.
>> Adam: Yeah.
>> Amy: But there's a question about April
getting pregnant in the hangout, so if you're
curious about that question hangout in the
hangout. OK, which, yes, go ahead Adam, sorry.
>> Adam: I would hope Leslie and Ben are still
dating in ten years, don't you?
>> Amy: Yeah I would think so.
>> Adam: And I would hope that they're still
very busy.
>> Amy: Yes.
>> Adam: Whether living in Washington, DC,
together, or in Pawnee together.
>> Amy: Right.
>> Adam: That's all I have to say. Sorry.
[laughter]
>> Amy: I liked your intense eye contact during
that. It was good.
>> Adam: I did.
>> Amy: OK, speaking of intense eye contact
and intensity, which actor on our cast would
win in an no holds barred fight? And which
character would win?
>> Chris: Nick Offerman and Ron Swanson.
>> Amy: Yeah.
>> Chris: Without question.
>> Amy: Nick has a really good sense of fighting.
>> Chris: Yeah.
>> Amy: And this low center of gravity. I
do think that maybe Jerry would kill everyone
though. [laughter]
>> Chris: But that'd be more like a office
machine gun type.
>> Amy: With like a machine gun? Yeah.
>> Adam: I feel like Jerry is one season away
from walking in there with a submachine gun
[Amy cracks up] and just taking everybody
out. Not Jim, but Jerry.
>> Amy: Not Jim, very different.
>> Adam: Jim is two seasons away. [laughter]
>> Amy: OK guys! Leslie's person that's like
her, you know, her like dream person to have
sex with is obviously Joe Biden. Who would
your characters, who was your, do you think
is your character's person?
>> Aubrey: Bill Pullman!
>>Amy: Bill Pullman! [laughs] Sure, yes
>> Aubrey: I think April was a really big
fan of his work in Casper when he played Devon
Sawa's dad. [laughter] All of her friends
like Devon Sawa but she liked Bill Pullman.
[laughter]
>> Amy: I see that.
>> Chris: Boy that's, I would say for a long
time it was the lead singer of Rush until
Andy found out it was a man. [laughter] He's
still high on the list [Amy cracks up] but
probably the Tracy Chapman. [laughter]
>> Adam: Absolutely!
>> Amy: Yeah.
>> Chris: Because their singing voices are
so similar.
>> Adam: Andy's and Tracy Chapman's?
>> Chris: My personal singing voice
>> Adam: And Tracy Chapman's
>> Chris: And Tracy Chapman's. Every time
I really actually, this is true, just sing,
you know? Sometimes you just throw the gloves
off when you sing. Exactly like Tracy Chapman.
>>Amy: Real singing.
>> Adam: I wonder if we could hear a little
of that like right now?
[Cheers and applause]
>> Chris: Man, I'll do it. But here's the
thing. It's going to be, I'm going to be vulnerable
because because I'm not doing a bit, I'm really
singing my heart out. And I sound like Tracy
Chapman.
>> Amy: Of course. Of course. Yeah, no, well
look Google talks about being vulnerable,
number one. [laughter]
>> Chris: OK. True.
>> Amy: Number two real singing is a real
thing and when you have to really sing and
you don't do a jokey sing, it's very, very
scary.
>> Chris: Yeah.
>> Amy: It's where you learn a lot about yourself.
>> Chris: True. I have to take some courage.
[laughter]
>> Amy: OK, everybody close their eyes.
>> Chris: [Singing] I drove a fast car, sounds
like Tracy Chapman when I sing.
[Applause]
>> Chris: Thanks, Thanks guys.
>> Amy: What about Ben? What's his, who's
his fantasy?
>> Adam: Janel Moloney from the West Wing.
[Laughing]
>> Amy: That's so specific and so true. OK.
>> Aubrey: What about?
>> Amy: Oh Leslie's is Joe Biden.
>> Aubrey: Oh right.
>> Amy: Yeah, yeah. But I think she has a
thing for Daniel Craig a little bit
>> Adam: Yep.
>> Amy: We've said she has a Daniel Craig
shaped body pillow. [laughter] And who else?
She probably wouldn't kick Sam Waterson out
of bed or something like that. [laughs] I'm
trying to think who she likes. OK, what's
the most surprising line or a story that you've
been given yet in the season. Like, or is
there, is there a surprising moment you got
that you were like, without spoiling anything
that you you're nodding your head that you're
of something.
>> Aubrey: This season?
>> Amy: Well, we don't want to spoil anything
this season, I guess, I don't' know. But if
there's a way you could say it without spoiling
it, yes. Or like, I'll offer this in season,
I forget which one it was, Leslie, you find
out Leslie's like kind of a hoarder, like
you go to her house and her stuff, her house
was filled to the capacity with books and
papers and I thought that was interesting
character trait. And I was like "OK! OK! This
is who she is. This is the love setting, but
nobody's perfect." Anybody else have anything
like that that they were given.
>> Chris: There's so many things like that,
I mean, I think Mike and all the writers make
it a point to surprise the audience and that
will, often times, surprises us. I remember
I was surprised in the wedding episode, where
when Andy was like the smallest sibling among
all of his brothers. Like, he'd been picked
on and pushed around like a little twerp his
whole life by these dudes who are like 6'8”
and 6'10”. That was surprising.
>> Amy: That was really, that was great detail.
Didn't really make the show, a lot got cut
out, but when you were getting married to
April, your brothers were there and the whole
time they were just pushing you. And punching
you in the balls while you were getting married.
[laughter]
>> Adam: I couldn't get enough of watching
you guys just like horsing around during the
wedding ceremony. It was really funny.
>> Chris: [laughs] It was fun.
>> Amy: [laughing] Really funny.
>> Chris: That's right, you sometimes forget,
being on this show, because we shoot so much
stuff, a lot of which doesn't make it to air,
because our episodes, half hour comedy, 21
and a half minutes, you know, with commercials.
We shoot maybe sometimes 38, 40 pages and
that should make for about 40 minutes episode.
So a lot of really great stuff ends up not
being shown on TV and so we have this idea
of all this stuff, but you forget that the
audience members might not know all that stuff.
I was really surprised that they actually
went, that we actually went to the Grand Canyon
to shoot the Grand Canyon rather than just
shoot it in front of a blue screen.
>> Amy: Plazie?
>> Aubrey: I don't know. I think for April
it's always surprising when she cares about
anything. [laughter] Or anyone. Which I like
those moments because you, I kind of, I feel
like I have two or three episodes where I'm
kind of, where she kind of just wreaks havoc
and doesn't care and then all of a sudden
there's like an episode where all of a sudden
she's being really nice to Chris Traeger and,
like, little, little glimpses of warm mushy
stuff comes through and I like that. And she
really likes animals.
>> Amy: That's right, she does like animals.
She loves them, she's good with them.
>> Aubrey: She's really good with the animals.
>> Amy: What about you Adam, what about Ben?
>> Adam: I don't know maybe his, the, his
love of Claymation was a big [laughter] is
really great. Like when you read these things
you have no idea what's coming down the pike
and so you get this script and you read these
hilarious things they write for you [chuckles]
and it kind of opens up this whole other world
to the character. It's really funny.
>> Amy: You have a proclivity for depression.
>> Adam: Yeah, yeah.
>> Amy: Ben, Ben does, Ben can go kind of
dark.
>> Adam: He's spins out if things just kind
of change a little bit and so it's really
fun, it's really funny.
>> Amy: Adam was dressed on set one time in
Ben's depressed clothes and I was like "hey!"
And he was like "Hey." Like I didn't even
know he was wearing depressing clothes as
his character.
>> Adam: It wasn't until later that you realized
it was my wardrobe.
>> Amy: I was like "Oh you are wearing Doc
Martins and a Letters to Cleo t-shirt. Those
aren't your clothes from home?”
OK, and why don't we explain, some people
want to know what a typical day is like on
set. Like a typical week or a typical day.
Can you guys explain that at all for people
who want to know what it's like working on
Parks?
>> Chris: Well it depends on who you talk
to, but for us, at least for me, it's real
easy. [laughter] Fucking awesome. It's great.
Typical day, 11 o clock rolls around I'm like,
"Oh God, I got to go to work in two hours."
[laughter] Walk down the hill, seven minutes
to get to work. Show up, park in a spot right
next to, like, a trailer, kind of like the
one I grew up in, but a little bigger. [laughter]
Go in there, hang out for a while, someone
will knock on the door "Hey Chris, they're
ready for you in hair and makeup." That usually
means in about 20 minutes I'm going to come
out. Go get my hair done. [Amy cracks up]
No, it's really fun. Our crew works really
hard, so it really depends on who you ask.
Because the people who, on the crew, will
work 60 hours a week and so for them a typical
day is rolling in around 7, working their
tails off getting all this stuff set up and
being there until 7 or 8 o'clock at night.
So it's a machine. I'm really lucky in that
I'm number 5 or 6, I'm down on the call sheet,
I might be in 8, 9 scenes in the whole episode,
so I get maybe two days off a week and not
even, don't even work full days when I work.
So for me it's, like I said it's super easy.
>> Amy: And you guys, everyone here has done
a lot of projects during the season and in
between the seasons, so everybody gets to
do a lot of different projects. Like, I think
you've all did about 5 movies over the break,
all of you. Various ways.
>> Adam: I think you did the most.
>> Amy: We all worked a lot.
>> Chris: Yeah, it gives you time because
it's a big, because we have an ensemble cast
it gives us time and there, our show runner,
the network, they're really, they really let
us go do other things and work around our,
allow our schedules to be flexible in that
way. And every time, don't you think? Every
time you go on and do something else do a
movie or work on something else, you come
back, their crews, they're never as tight
as Parks' crews.
>> Amy: Yeah, I got to, maybe we're being
we're well whatever, it's true. Which is that
we shoot really fast and because it's mockumentary
style, we never really know where the cameras
are and there's not a lot of waiting around
for cameras and lighting and stuff. And everybody's
on, on, on screen most of the time. So like
you never know when you're going to be talking
or someone's going to improvise, so you never
have that thing that you see in films where
I'm off camera giving Adam lines, like that
never happens. If we're doing a scene, we
just do it together over and over again which
you get kind of used to and it's really great,
I think, for comedy.
>> Adam: Yeah, I remember I came in late to
the show and they were already up and running
when I started and I remember my first day.
I came and did a scene with you and Nick [chuckles]
and we just did the scene, like, five times
and then we were done with the scene rather
than doing it 20 times and taking a break
and doing it another 20. There's cameras all
over and they just capture everything and
I couldn't believe how quick it was. It's
really fun that way, I think.
>> Amy: It was also sometimes the cameras
that they have the spy shots and so you don't
actually know even know where the cameras
are. That can be, we joke around that we like
spy shots because it just makes your acting
look better. [giggles] But because it's this
long lens and it just, but it is cool to do
scenes in rooms where nobody's in there but
you. It feels, like, real sexy. OK.
>> Adam: There's a real intimacy to it, you
know what I mean?
>> Amy: Shut up.
>> Adam: No, it's like a connection with like.
I'll talk about it at the hangout. [laughter]
>> Aubrey: But I'm like Chris, I feel like
a normal day for Amy is probably a lot different.
Because normally, I feel like the girls have
to come, you know, especially on Monday's
like 5:30 in the morning, really early and
usually I walk in and I see you and you're
there and you're never late and I'm always
late.
>> Amy: I'm always a little; I'm a little
bit late sometimes.
>> Aubrey: Really?
>> Amy: I'm like ten minutes late, it's a
problem.
>> Aubrey: Well, I'm always early and I
>> Adam: Wait I just thought you said.
>> Aubrey: Well, whatever. [laughter] Sometimes
I get in really early and I don't talk to
anyone for as long as I can. And I usually
go in my trailer and stare at myself in the
mirror and think about my choices and my regrets.
[laughter] I just, yeah, that's how a day
starts.
>> Amy: Yeah, I'll see Aubrey in the morning
and I'll say "Hi ,Aubrey." And she'll be like
"Aubrey's dead. April's here now."
>> Chris: Yeah.
>> Amy: It's really cool stuff; we'll talk
about it in the hangout.
>> Chris: That's hangout stuff.
>> Amy: That's hangout stuff. This is Google
talk. We want to open up this part of the
Google talk to let you talk to see if anybody
has any questions that they would like to
ask us before we go into the hangout, which
is when things are really going get down and
dirty.
>> Adam: We are so hyping up this hangout.
[laughter]
>> Amy: We should change into pajamas for
the hangout. OK, so yes.
>> Presenter: Yeah, I'll start off with a
question and then you can approach the mic
as you have questions as well.
>> Amy: Thank you.
>> Announcer: So I wanted, one of the real
highlights of Parks and Rec, are the behind
scenes characters, the birds, the murals on
the wall, like, how did those go about, how
have they developed, any interesting anecdotes
about that.
>> Amy: Yeah, that is such a credit to Mike
Schur and Greg Daniels and the writers that
all that world that Pawnee world exists and
that we bring people back, like Joan Callamezzo,
who is our kind of TV personality, and Perd
Hapley who is our hapless television news
reporter. People kind of come in and out of
the world and they come back a lot. One of
the new characters that I just particularly
like that came back, that is back again this
season, is Ethel Beavers is like the court,
kind of, stenographer and she's the one that
last season told Leslie that Ben loved her
because she just read back the transcript.
And she's the, and those are the kind of the
people that when they show up everyone's like
"Ethel Beavers is here!" And we like to think
that the audience thinks that too, so. That
those kind of, there's so many characters
like that. Like who are people.
>> Aubrey: Like Kyle
>> Adam: Yeah.
>> Aubrey: Kyle's a funny one because I feel
like he's the guy at the shoe shine stand
that, that is only character that is below
Jerry, I think, [laughter] that is in the
social hierarchy of it all. But he was funny
because he, we I didn't know he was coming
back and he just said like one line and they
kept bringing him back and back and how he's
got like this whole thing with Jerry. And
he's, so it's kind of fun when you see someone
over and over again.
>> Amy: Yeah, we haven't seen Kyle for a while.
>> Adam: I ran into him at Sharky's the other
day. [laughter]
>> Chris: Did you smack him?
>> Adam: Yeah, I ignored him.
>> Chris: And it's really, what's great about
episodic, especially a show like this, Dean
Hall and I don't know if we've ever given
him a shout out but he deserves a lot of credit.
He's a head editor and also directs a lot
of the episodes and his voice is really a
large part of Parks and Rec's comedy. And,
I think, because it's always evolving you
go from one episode to the next and as one,
episodes play, writers are still in the room
creating things, so a lot of the guys that
you see come back they come back because they
made Dean laugh in the editing room. And so
that Kyle stuff makes them laugh, or the,
oh who, who recently just played, she's like
the super straight-laced Christian conservative.
>> Amy: Darlene Hunt who plays Marcia Langman,
who's kind of the uptight society for parents
and social people and people together and
whatever and she's always protesting the sexy
stuff and she comes back in an episode we
just did and it's great to see her back. And
all the crazy talents people we use a lot
of them because they show up at the meeting
a lot. And we had great, you know, we always,
we've been really lucky to have such great
people come join our show, cast-wise and guest
cast-wise and last season we had Louis C.
K. come back and Kathryn Hahn and Paul Rudd.
And this season, we just did, you saw on the
clip, Jon Glaser comes and plays a really
uptight councilman named Councilman Jan, who
gets gets jams things up. And we have a lot
of other good people coming down. Lucy Lawless
is with us now, playing a possible love interested
for Ron. [laughter]
>> Chris: Lucy Lawless was Xena warrior princess
if you don't know, she's
>> Adam: And still is to my mind.
>> Amy: Still is.
>> Chris: Yeah
>> Adam: One of our writers, Harris Wittels,
comes back as animal control a lot which is,
always super funny.
>> Amy: That's right, that's right.
>> Chris: so those guys earn it, they get
laughs and that's why they come back.
>> Amy: Question?
>> Male #1: On the same note, as far as guest
stars go, is there any actor you would love
to come onto the show? Jason Statham, maybe,
someone like that, just come on there.
>> Amy: Do you know Jason Statham? [laughter]
>> Male #1: I wish.
>> Amy: That'd be sweet. Only if he's, if
we call him the Transporter. Well I've been
very vocal about my dream would be to have
Bill Murray, be on in any way, just because
I think he would, well, because he's my comedic
hero and because I think he would fit in Pawnee
some how. We have a mayor on our show that
we talk about a lot that we've never seen
that would be my dream to have him play that.
Anybody else that you guys?
>> Chris: I really want Dave Matthews to be
on just so that I could, so that Andy could
meet him and cry. [laughter] I don't know
how it happens.
>> Adam: That would be great.
>> Amy: That would be great.
>> Adam: If he gets on and plays with Mouse
Rat. [laughter]
>> Chris: Oh God, that would be Andy's dream,
can you imagine? Or maybe like Darius Rucker,
or like Eddie Vedder, or just someone like
that who's just like was a big 90s iconic
rocker, that would be sweet.
>> Aubrey: I really like, like Rosie Perez
to be like my aunt.
>> Amy: Yessss!
>> Chris: That would be sweet.
>> Aubrey: Or like someone really likes spicy
and Latina to come and be one of my family
members.
>> Amy: To be your Tia?
>> Aubrey: Yeah. That's right. [laughter]
>> Amy: Oh my God, I love you. And Adam, what
about you?
>> Adam: I don't know. We've had some great
ones, so far this year; we've had some senators
come in when we're in DC which was really
great.
>> Amy: That right.
>> Adam: That was a real experience. The four
of us were in DC together and it was a real
amazing experience working with them.
>> Amy: If you are watching the Google talk
and you are at minute 40 and you don't know
this, our show premiers on September 20 and
we go to visit April and Ben in DC. I have
a feeling if you've watched this long then
you know that.
>> Adam: Yeah.
>> Amy: Because if you don't know of the show,
why the [whispers]fuck would be watching this.
But anyway we go and visit we visit Ben's
character and we have some senators come visit
us, too. OK question over here.
>> Male #2: Oh yes, in the first seasons The
Pit was a really big part of the show and
I was just curious like do you guys miss it,
or are you glad you don't have to go to The
Pit anymore anything like that? [Amy and Aubrey
laugh]
>> Amy: The Pit is was emblematic of Leslie's
futile attempts to try to make change, so
it's changed slowly. Now, it's not actually
a pit, now it's a grassy field that we go
to. And we have events on this field. But,
yes, in the beginning, the first, the first
thing I ever shot for the show was a promo
in the pit with trash swirling around me and
Aziz Ansari was like "Hey, I found a bra!"
like in the Pit and it was like "We're going
build a park." It was just dusty and it was
super hot and I remember thinking "Oh my God,
I hate the pit." So and a lot of us fell into
the Pit many times, too. You fell into the
Pit you used to live in the Pit. [laughter]
>> Chris: I lived in the pit. That was the
worst. [Adam laughs] It's out in the valley,
it got really hot out there and I'd come home
and have like dirt in my eyes from the Pit.
I was like "Fuck the Pit!" But it's really,
it was a great, a mine for comedy which is
great, but, boy, it was just not comfortable
to be in it. It was super gross.
>> Amy: I think you may find some stuff happening
this season at the Pit. The Pit's not gone
away. It's like our hatch. [laughter] Oh my
God, I finally got some reaction out of this.
[laughter] Now I know what Google likes.
>> Adam: Smoke monster
>> Male #3: Obviously all you guys are very
funny, but who on the cast would you say is
the funniest and, on the flip side, who is
the most serious about their craft?
>> Amy: Well, that's hard to say. I'm going
to say Pratt's the funniest.
>> Aubrey: Yeah, I agree.
>> Adam: Yeah
>> Chris: I'm going to say I'm the most serious
about my craft. It's kind of both.
[Inaudible]
>> Amy: So there you go.
>> Chris: Next question
>> Amy: Next question
>> Male #4: I know he wasn't able to make
it today but Michael Schur actually went to
my high school and graduated with my sister,
so if he was here, do you think he'd remember
her? [laughter] And give her a shout out?
>> Amy: What's your sister's name?
>> Male #4: Robin Dinowitz, of course
>> Amy: OK, I'm going to ask ask him about
her, I'm sure he would, he's a very very
>> Chris: He just yelled into the computer.
[laughter] No, he doesn't. Sorry, so sorry.
>> Adam: I I'm wondering,Sir, if graduated
with your sister is a euphemism?
>> Male #4: I hope it is, yes. [laughter]
>> Amy: Magna cum laude doing on your sister
>> Chris: Magna cum louder
>> Amy: [laughs] OK, yeah, I don't need groans
from you.
>> Male #5: Thank you guys so much for coming
love the show. Just wondering what is the
biggest way in which each of you differs from
your character?
>> Amy: That's a good question.
>> Aubrey: Maybe we could answer for each
other.
>> Amy: OK.
>> Chris: That's really good. [laughter]
>> Aubrey: Why?
>> Adam: That sounds fun and super personal.
>> Aubrey: Or not.
>> Adam: No.
>> Amy: OK
>> Adam: Amy, how does Chris differ from Andy?
>> Amy: OK. Well, I think Chris is a better
listener than Andy, because Andy doesn't listen
at all. And Chris is a better listener and
he's just much more put together than Andy
is. I think Andy is a little bit more handsome
than Chris.
[Laughter]
>> Amy: And that's something that Chris has
to kind of work through. But I would say that.
I would say that, I would say that Chris is
not as, like as, as checked out as Andy is.
Well, let's hope so. [laughs] OK, Plaza you
answer for Adam.
>> Aubrey: OK I think that Amy is funnier
and
sexier than Leslie, you know, could ever imagine
being, ever.
>> Amy: Thank you, all I heard was sexier
so I'll take it. [laughter]
>> Amy: OK, Adam, I'm going to answer for
you. I think, you are, you, oh my God, this
is going to so dirty and I just gotta stop
myself. No, no, no! I saw your reaction to
magna cum loudy. [laughter] I'm not going
there again. OK, no, what I think, [laughs]
no I think, you know Adam likes to drive barefoot
and he's from Santa Cruz so he's a lot more,
you're much more like, you're less tightly
wound, I think, than Ben is.
>> Adam: Bro, listen, if you're wearing flip
flops and you're driving a car it's unsafe
to keep the flip flop on am I right? [audience
responds] [applause]
>> Amy: No, OK, but why do you think it's
OK to drive barefoot?
>> Adam: Who, how do you think people drove
before there were shoes?
[Laughter]
>> Amy: That's a good point. No that's a good
point. OK.
>> Adam: I'm going to say Aubrey and April,
for the first year that I was on the show
I didn't think there was a difference. [laughter]
But now I, there really is two completely
different people. In what ways? I don't know.
[laughter]
>> Chris: It's, I mentioned, I said this earlier
to someone, it was, I don't remember where,
some interview. [chuckles] No, I was talking
about Aubrey and obviously Andy and April
are married and we work very closely with
one another and I said that it's a shame for
people like David Letterman and Jay Leno and
Conan O'Brien that they'll never actually
get to meet Aubrey. And I think that's the
case with a lot of people. Especially in this
kind of environment where it's a press type,
this isn't press, but you know it's a situation
where you're where you're on. I think Aubrey's
on a lot, a lot of the time and that and its,
she's like Andy Kaufman or something you know.
She's kind of, she would meet the president
and take it as an opportunity to do a bit,
you know. She would be like, I don't know.
>> Amy: We went, well, yeah
>> Chris: I think she would you know she would
meet the president and see it as an opportunity
to do a bit. But for the lucky few people
who get a chance to know her, she's totally
different than April. April's a character
that's sort of like, that likes to mess with
people and those are similarities obviously
because they are sort of, they are born out
of who Aubrey is. She likes to fuck with people
and get a rise out of people and make people
uncomfortable. And it's amusing to her. [laughter]
And but apart from all that she's very, very
caring and sweet and a good listener and would
be there for her friends in a heartbeat. And
that's a really nice.
>> Amy: Yes, hear, hear,
>> Aubrey: And also I have to say, Chris is
one of even though Andy is very stupid, Chris
is one of the smartest actors I've ever worked
with ever.
>> Amy: We said he was the funniest.
>> Aubrey: Right, but I'm saying he's the
smartest.
>> Adam: And now he's also the smartest.
>> Amy: Smartest.
[Applause]
>> Amy: Yes, question.
>> Male #6: I was wondering how often do you
improvise and go off script during filming
and how often does that actually make it onto
the air?
>> Amy: We are lucky in our process, where
first of all our scripts are always great
and what you see 99% of it is what was written
in the script and then maybe 1 or 2% an episode
is stuff that we improvise. But we get to
improvise which sometimes is just enough.
Because you get to be like "Can I do my stupid
idea?" [giggles] And then you get to do it
and you're like "Oh you're right that idea,
my idea's stupid." But we do, we get to do
what we call on set we call it a fun run which
is we do the scene until we have it and then
we get to do a version after we know it where
we kind of fool around. And every once in
a while, bits of it get on the show, or but
usually it's longer and less funny than what
was written in the script. [laughter]
>> Chris: And it's only fun for us, it's not
fun for like the camera operator who's like
"OK great 7 minutes, this is all going to
make it."
>> Amy: Yes.
>> Female #1: Amy, is your husband ever going
to be a guest star on the show. I love watching
you two together.
>> Amy: He was on season two.
>> Female 1: Oh he was! I missed it.
>> Amy: Yeah, he played a, people who gave
MRIs or EKGs, MRIs he was an MRI technician.
>> Female #1: What about Hillary Clinton?
>> Amy: Hillary Clinton is not my husband.
Yet. But my God, I would love for Hillary
Clinton to be on.
>> Female #1: That would be cool.
>> Amy: Oh, wouldn't it be cool?
>> Female #1: Yeah.
>> Amy: I just saw a cool picture of her that
reminded, I sent it to Adam today there's
a really cool picture of Hillary watching
Bill's speech. Did anyone see it today? I'm
sure you all saw, you guys are like "Yeah,
I see everything, I work at Google." You're
like "Yeah, the thing that was on the internet,
I saw it."
>> Chris: "The thing that we put on the internet
that you saw, yeah."
>> Amy: Yeah, the one I created.
>> Adam: "You saw it, thanks to us."
>> Amy: And it was just a cool picture of
her on the computer watching him and Leslie
and Ben Skype a lot in the first couple of
episodes of Parks because they're, you know,
away, they're separated, so I thought that
was a cool image. I mean that would be amazing
if she would do it. She would be great.
>> Female #2: Great question, I had a kind
of follow up thing, is there any chance that
the Pawnee folk might take a roadtrip through
O.C. for Arrested Development or vice versa,
the Arrested Development crew visit Pawnee?
How would that play out?
>> Amy: Oh God, no! Well, let me ask you guys
this, what do you think we should do a crossover
with? What show?
>>Male #7: Party down?
>>Amy: Party down, well we are, we are. Arrested,
yeah.
>>Male #8: Gossip Girl
>>Amy: Gossip, [laughter] we should go, we
should just be like
>> Aubrey: Go to New York?
>> Amy: We'd go to New York and well we would
be just horrible, like poorly dressed extras
in the back of a Gossip Girl scene.
>> Adam: We should do a crossover with Vampire
Diaries.
>> Amy: Well, Ian Somerhalder, he looks like
Rob Lowe's younger, he looks like Rob Lowe's
son or brother.
>> Adam: He does. [laughter]
>> Amy: Wait a minute, Adam.
>> Adam: I think I've stumbled onto something.
>> Amy: So we'll get that going.
>>Presenter: So I wanted to close with one
final question then. So for people who watch
this show, ordinary viewers, is there any
one thing that most people overlook that you'd
like to point out to them, whether it's like
an Easter egg, something subtle.
>> Amy and Adam: That's a good question.
>> Chris: Is there something that people were
overlook?
>> Presenter: That they may not see, like
some you know caricature in the background
is really a writer in the mural.
>> Adam: Well the the photos of all the councilmen
over the years in the hallway have some of
our writer producers up there. And
>> Amy: That's a good one, yeah. We
>> Adam: Morgan Sackett is up there, so is
Norm Hiscock who is a writer.
>> Amy: Dan Gore
>> Adam: Dan Gore, Mike Schur, they're all
up on this wall, which is-- Who else is up
there?
>> Amy: There's a lot of things in in the
Parks department, like when you walk by there
will be like this, like a beautiful statute
of like the founder of the town and his name
is Greg Daniels, stuff like that. But I don't
know how much of it's actually made it on
the air, those kind of things.
>> Adam: It's a great set to come and give
a tour to to people on because there's so
much, do you, open up a drawer and it's filled
with things that have been on the show and
just little bits of history all over it. It's
very, kind of, it's very real; it's like a
real office.
>> Aubrey: Also if you ever see anything at
with April at her desk and you notice her
the many notebooks or papers, there's usually
plenty of drawings of penises on, [laughter]
because usually when I'm at the desk and I'm
just writing or working in the background
I'm just drawing penises over and over.
>> Amy: There you go. That would be considered
an Easter egg right? [laughter]
>>Presenter: I think so. So with that, Pawnee,
greatest town in America. Thank you for stopping
by at Google!
>> All: Thank you!
[Applause and cheering]